[Musique]
je pense que c'est l'album le plus
personnel que j'ai pu faire parce que je
mets tous mes sentiments et mes
influences dedans on vous dira plus
c'est pourquoi je suis très content de
cet album grâce à sa spiritualité sa
sensibilité
le pouvoir du rythme c'est magnifique je
suis très excité par cet album et je
sais que j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui ont
aimé cet album donc je suis très content
pour moi c'est très important d'avoir
différentes couleurs
quand vous avez plusieurs couleurs ça
veut dire que vous parlez en plusieurs
langues à travers la musique
[Musique]
au regard de renom on donne toujours à
fond
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir sur cet album
joe lovano un joueur de saxophone
ibrahim maalouf joueur de trompette
d'année suarez j'aime vraiment beaucoup
ce qu'elle fait
pourtant c'est pas nouveau pour moi
c'est très important de jouer avec des
gens qui croient en ce qu'ils font ils
défendent ce qu'ils font les médias le
marché pousse certaines personnes à
faire autre chose pour avoir plus
d'argent ou pour vendre plus d'albums ou
ce genre de choses
10 mais ces artistes sont vraiment
spéciaux c'est pourquoi je suis très
content très honoré de les avoir sur cet
album comme chaque fois que je viens ici
en france pour moi c'est très important
20 12
parce qu'en france vous avez différents
publics
il ya quelques coins en france où les
gens sont plus conservateurs il aimerait
danser mais ils sont trop timides pour
danser il y a une autre partie où ils
deviennent floues en dansant et
s'exprimer eux mêmes et j'aime ça parce
que la musique c'est pour tout le monde
mais toujours voulu montrer ma musique
au public français
[Musique]
e